SPEAKER: In the
previous videos, we've
seen how the Oboe
library makes it
easy to play low
latency audio, but what
if you need to record audio.
In this video, I'll show you
how to set up low latency
streams for recording.
Recording audio is done in much
the same way as playing audio.
The main difference is that
our audio stream moves data
from an audio
device, for example,
the built in microphone,
rather than sending data to it.
Before creating an
input audio stream,
you'll need to make sure
that your app has acquired
the record audio permission.
To create the
input audio stream,
we use an audio stream builder,
setting stream direction
to input and the performance
mode to low latency.
Now we can open the stream
by passing a reference
to an audio stream pointer.
After checking that
it opens successfully,
you can start the stream.
Data from the default
recording device
will start moving
into the stream.
There are two ways we
can read this data--
either directly or
using a callback.
It's possible to
obtain the lowest
latency using both approaches.
I'll demonstrate how to read
directly from the stream
since the callback method was
covered in the previous video.
The method we need is
unsurprisingly called read.
It takes three parameters.
Buffer is an array into which
the audio data will be read.
Numb frames is the number
of audio frames to read,
and time out nanoseconds
is the maximum number
of nanoseconds which the
method will block for.
If you specify 0
here, the method
will return immediately,
copying only the data that
was currently available
in the streams buffer.
This is useful if you don't want
to block the current thread.
So let's say we wanted to read
two milliseconds of audio data
from a 16-bit mono audio stream.
We can do this using
a blocking read.
Start by creating an array
to store the frames of audio.
The amount of data
we need to store
will depend on the
streams sample rate.
The timeout should be longer
than the amount of audio
we want to read.
In this case, we'll
use 3 milliseconds,
and convert it to nanoseconds.
Incidentally, Oboe provides
a number of useful constants
for working with
different time units.
Before we can read
from our stream,
we need to clear out any
stale data which might already
be in the streams buffer.
To do this, we just
perform non-blocking reads
of the whole buffer
until it's empty.
Now, when we read
from the stream,
we know we're reading the
most current audio data.
After the read is completed,
we need to check the result.
If it was OK, then
result of value
will contain the
number of frames which
were copied into our buffer.
To read more data, surround
this block in a wild loop.
This approach
allows us to process
small buffers of up
to date audio data
for processing and
moving elsewhere.
After we're done, we
must close the stream.
And after a stream
has been closed,
it can no longer be accessed.
This is a very simple example
of how to record audio.
For more complex
examples, including
how to implement synchronous
recording and playback,
check out the live
effects sample on GetHub.
You can also check out the
other videos in this series.
The first video is an
introduction to Oboe,
and shows why low latency
audio is important.
And the second
video shows you how
to create low latency audio
streams for playing sound.
That's all for now.
If you have any questions,
issues, or feature requests,
please post them in the issues
section of the Oboe GetHub
site.
We'd really love
to hear from you.
Good luck, and go
make some noise.